hallo ihr lieben ich wünsche euch ein
frohes neues und vor allem gesundes jahr
2019 wir starten ins jahr mit einem
gesunden rezept ich habe im letzten
monat ganz viele süße so mächtige sachen
gezeigt die aber auch sehr lecker waren
ich bereue es nicht die gemacht zu haben
aber wir starten jetzt mal gesund ins
neue jahr und dafür zeige ich euch eine
tolle frühstücks idee wir machen gesunde
pancakes aus nur vier zutaten die zeige
ich euch jetzt
wir benötigen keine haferflocken mit
eurer wahl eine banane und etwas
backpulver der teig ist so schnell
hergestellt das schafft ihr also locker
morgens noch vor der schule vor der uni
oder vor der arbeit ich gebe zuerst die
kernigen haferflocken in meinen länder
und dann wird sich das ungefähr 30
sekunden
so als nächstes kommen milch und die
banane rein und bei der milch könnt ihr
natürlich variieren ihr könnt auch
sojamilch nehmen
laktosefreie ganz wie ihr möchtet und
die banane die mache ich jetzt klein
gebe ich da auch noch mit rein so der
teig ist so schon fertig ich gebe jetzt
noch meinen backpulver 1 und wird es
auch nochmal kurz unter mixen ihr könnt
natürlich auch backpulver weglassen habe
ich finde die konsistenz dann immer ein
bisschen schöner aber wie gesagt es
funktioniert auch ohne backpulver der
teig ist jetzt prinzipiell schon fertig
aber lasst ihn noch mal zehn minuten
stehen der zwischenzeit könnt ihr schon
mal euro fahne bereitlegen hermann
schmeißen aber zu verstehen dass man
arbeitet erst noch mal ja also wer jetzt
noch einmal proteinpulver rhein haben
möchte gerne ein esslöffel noch rein
hauen dann habt ihr noch mal ein
richtiger eiweiß bombe so und jetzt habe
ich hier meinen kreisen bitte nicht
wundern das geht natürlich auch einer
beschichteten pfanne hier sind aus
organisatorischen gründen einfach besser
weil man hört auf der anderen seite ist
und ihr film nun mal so und jetzt gebe
ich ein bisschen back transport raus
natürlich geht auch kokos irgendwann zu
ihr möchtet und die jetzt habe ich einen
kleinen tipp für euch nehmt euch am
besten ein eis portionierer dann sind
auch alle pancakes gleich groß und jetzt
werden sie von jeder seite so ungefähr
zwei minuten ausgebaut
[Musik]
und fertig sind die gesunden pancakes
wie ihr ohne reue genießen könnt gerne
auch mit zur schule wird zur uni nehmen
können die schmeckt nämlich auch kalt
selbst ausgetestet oder zur arbeit genau
und ich freue mich jetzt ganz natürlich
nach macht aber schreibt mir vorher
unbedingt kommentar was ihr noch so
sehen möchtet an gesunden rezepten oder
alternativen also unbedingt kommentar
hinterlassen
die genauen zutaten und mengenangaben
schreibe ich euch immer unten in der
infobox kurzer hinweis ihr bekommt
ungefähr zwölf bis vierzehn pantex raus
so relativ kleine aber wenn sie noch
größer macht dann ist natürlich euch
überlassen so und jetzt freue ich mich
benehmen kann abonniert beim nächsten
mal natürlich auch wieder dabei sein
[Musik]